all right let's follow the 2024 campaign
Trail around the weekend and take a look
at what happened Donald Trump was
scheduled to do another one of these
unhinged lie rallies the lie a second
it's not even lie a minute it's the
lia's second rally in Des Moines Iowa
that rally was ultimately canceled it
was reportedly canceled for bad weather
although there are some who are saying
it was canceled because there were no
people and Trump realized it would be
humiliating so we opted to cancel it I
don't know officially it was canceled
for bat for bad weather this didn't stop
the sycophants and dilettants from uh
showing up and uh praising the cult
leader and really proving Beyond any
doubt whatsoever that this is a cult I'm
going to show you a few examples of this
at the rally that did not happen
here is a guy who was asked you know
Trump's doing a rally in Iowa Ron
DeSantis is also doing an event in Iowa
even though he's not yet running and
this guy says he felt an obligation to
be at the Trump rally why I'll let him
explain it to you I wasn't important
Wednesday we've got DeSantis in the same
state today but you guys chose to be
here for president Trump what was the
decision-making process there you want
to go first I think all of the attacks
against President Trump that are just
totally unprecedented you know the legal
allegations against him I just feel
obligated knowing how much president
Trump has stood up for me and has stood
up for all of these Americans I feel
obligated to come out here and show my
support for him yeah what now see this
is where like if we had Luke Beasley on
the ground he would follow up and say oh
in what way did Trump stand up for you
well he stood up to China for me oh
really how did he stand up to China and
you very quickly see that it's
completely vapid it's just there's
absolutely no substance whatsoever there
then they go to the the guy next to him
with basically the same question
DeSantis is in the state of Iowa Trump
was scheduled to be in the state of Iowa
before the rally got canceled why why
are you here instead of at the DeSantis
event and listen to what this guy says
it's beyond parody
well for his country and not his country
for his not his country for his wealth
Trump earned
1.6 billion dollars personally during
his presidency think about the level of
Disconnect with these people Trump did
something no one else has ever done he
traded his wealth for the country for
the good of the country
he earned 1.6 billion dollars during the
four years that he was supposedly
working for this guy's interests as
president of the United States then they
speak to we're still dealing with the
same group of folks they speak to one of
the women I guess and say if you had the
chance to speak to Donald Trump what
would you say to him
Eric and badass that we have been
waiting for and we thank you you're like
our father our protector and we love you
thank you
folks
folks intervention
is the word that comes to mind this is a
very deep and troubled cult and this is
the sort of you know there was a time
I I know people sometimes get upset when
I do this there was a time where if you
went and in fact you can look at this on
YouTube and I know some people say David
you're you're glamorizing terrible okay
just bear with me if you go on YouTube
and you find examples of right Wingers
from the 60s and 70s who would go to for
example a William F Buckley gnome
Chomsky debate or something like that
and they would get on the mic and they
would ask a question okay they will seem
like the most sane and rational
intellectuals compared to these folks
now in fact if you look at the Trump CNN
Town Hall from last week and you look at
the questions that were asked people who
can barely string a sentence together
and then you look at the folks that
would engage you know with William F
Buckley and others in the 60s 70s 80s of
the United States the right
I am on the left okay so I would come to
different conclusions on policy than
these folks but there were people on the
right in the United States back then
who didn't seem obviously like empty
vessels just following a cult leader
without understanding a word about it
you you go and look at there's some very
interesting videos on YouTube where the
economist Milton Friedman takes
questions from the audience and some of
the questions are from people on the
left and some of the questions are for
people on the right the level of
discourse was
you just can't even compare it to what
has happened to this country
particularly from the anti-intellectual
and pseudo-intellectual left where
college is liberal indoctrination and
books are and all of this stuff
and this is where we end up with cult
members that's where we are at this
point in time here's a guy from the same
rally that was postponed
who without evidence says to the anchors
of real America's voice
someone from New York has been paying
for my dad's cancer treatment
and I'm sure it's Donald Trump
what do you have any evidence of that no
but I'm just sure but my dad hasn't
received a cancer bill in over five
years and it's been paid
um 100 percent by a guy in New York and
that can only be president Donald J
Trump and my dad's cancer-free yeah
that's just made up guys there's no
reason whatsoever to and by the way
Trump hasn't lived in New York for years
Trump famously while he was President
changed his residency to Florida like
just none of this makes sense there's no
thinking there's no thinking that's
happening here it is just people praying
at the altar of the cult leader Trump
the question of the E Gene Carroll case
did come up in interviews with some of
these supporters we'll go back to that
earlier group we looked at and they were
asked well what do you think about the E
Gene Carroll thing and here's what they
had to say women for Trump
are you deterred At All by any of the
recent allegations against him or are
you just supporting Trump through and
through because you know that he's an
honest man we think that it's a lie and
yeah
and he's a good guy they just don't like
it because he's standing up for America
they have demonized him because he's the
one standing up for We the People he's
the only President the only person who
has ever stood up for We the People he's
on our side and that's why he's been
demonized because all the systems that
have been in control are rigged right
a jury which included trumpists okay
found that Trump was liable for the
sexual assault and defamation of e Gene
Carroll because the jury was angry that
Trump stood up for the American people
you sound I sound like an idiot
repeating it it's it's so stupid it
doesn't make any sense whatsoever here's
one last clip uh folks proudly talking
about the parts of the country they came
from to see this rally tornado watch be
damned
doing great a little wet but I'm drying
off
you're here during the little the little
rain yes after it had to ring my clothes
out now did people stay did people run
what was it like I never saw anyone
leave
incredible incredible I got a video
actually of just hundreds of people
waiting out here earlier hundreds and
they didn't they didn't move a muscle
they stayed right here waiting to show
their support for proudly ignoring
dangerous weather president Trump now
speaking of support for president Trump
the front row Joe's have always been
some of the most vocal supporters I want
to know today where each of you all came
from when did you leave how far is that
Journey hey Becky we left the day before
yesterday and just took our time I'm
from Tennessee I came with Mike Bowman
he's from Indiana Mike Bowden Becky
South Dakota six hours
[Music]
how far did you travel and when did you
leave I came here yesterday it took me
about 11 hours from Ohio okay so as you
can see
a badge of honor the more that you have
struggled and the more that you have
suffered to be in the presence of the
great leader
the more commitment you have
demonstrated this is straight out of a
cult Playbook straight out of a call you
you brag about who has toiled and
suffered the most to be here today scary
stuff many of these people vote Trump
could win in 2024 and so we need to be
on our guard
one of our sponsors is zipx nicotine
toothpicks don't you think it's time you
stopped putting smoke and vape oils in
your lungs zippix toothpicks are a
convenient way to curb the nicotine
Cravings zipx toothpicks are super
discreet you can use them anytime
anywhere smoking and vaping aren't
allowed including flights sporting
events in restaurants they're available
in six different flavors with options of
two and three milligrams of nicotine if
you're not a nicotine user zipix also
offers caffeine and b12 infused
toothpicks zipx has already helped tens
of thousands of customers ditch the
cigarettes ditch the Vapes they might be
able to help you too if you're a smoker
or a vapor give zipx toothpicks a try
your lungs will thank you go to
zipxtoothpix.com today save 10 with the
code pacman10 at checkout out just
remember you must be 21 or older to
order the link is down below